Let's take a look at authentication.
That is, Alice needs to prove to Bob
that she's really Alice, and vice versa.
Meaning that Bob needs to
prove to Alice that he is Bob.
Suppose that Alice and
Bob share a secret key, KAB.
That is, only Bob and
Alice know this key, KAB.
Here's an authentication protocol
using symmetricartography.
First Alice says to Bob, hey I'm Alice.
Second, Bob said to Alice, really?
Prove it.
And he sends a random value R1,
which we will call a challenge.
Third, Alice then encrypts
R1 using the shared key KAB.
And sends Bob the cybertext, which we'll
call it the response to the challenge.
When Bob receives the response,
he decrypts it and
see if it matches the plain text,
R1 that he just sent to Alice.
If it matches, then he knows that the
party that he's communicating with must
be Alice, because R then, himself,
only Alice knows the shared key KAB.
And without KAB,
R1 cannot be encrypted properly.
That is the server text that he receives
won't be decrypted properly to R1.
Fourth, now it is Alice's
turn to authenticate Bob.
So, similarly,
she sends Bob a random challenge, R2.
Fifth, Bob encrypts R2 with the shared
key KAB and sends a cyber text to Alice.
Upon receiving the response from Bob,
Alice decrypts the cyber text and
if the result matches the plain
text R2 that she just sent to Bob,
then she knows that the party that
she's communicating with must be Bob.
Note that if only one-way
authentication is required, for
example, Alice is a client and
needs to authenticate to Bob,
which is a server, but Bob does
not need to authenticate to Alice,
then only the first three
steps are necessary.
And if Alice is a human user,
then typically the key KAB
can be derived from a password hash,
which is known to Bob.
We just discussed how challenge and
response are used in authentication.
It is very important for
the challenges, say R1 and R2,
to be not easily repeatable or
predictable.
Otherwise an intruder such as
Trudy can record the challenge and
response between Alice and Bob and
replay them to impersonate Alice or Bob.
For example,
an intruder called Trudy wants to
impersonate either Alice or Bob.
Suppose Trudy has spent time recording
the authentication messages between
Alice and Bob across multiple sessions.
Now, if when Trudy tries to impersonate
Alice and Bob happens to send R1,
a challenge that has been used
previously and recorded by Trudy, then
Trudy can just simply send the response
that she has recorded from Alice.
That is, Trudy is able to send
the cyber text of R1 to Bob and
Bob will be tricked to
believe that she is Alice.
As another example, suppose the
challenges always increase in values.
Then Trudy can first impersonate Bob and
send a large challenge,
say R1 equal to 1000, and
record the response from Alice.
Meanwhile, the real Bob
is using a smaller R1,
say R1 equal to 950, then Trudy
can impersonate Alice some time in
the future when the real Bob
finally sends R1 equal to 1,000.
To recap, first of all,
the messages that were sent over
the Internet can be
captured by intruder Trudy.
And our job is to prevent these
messages being replayed so
that Trudy can't impersonate Alice and
Bob.
And in order to do that,
the random challengers R1 and
R2 should really be not easily
repeatable or predictable.
Again, the most important precaution
of using this authentication protocol
is that R1 and R2 should not be
easily repeatable or predictable.
Otherwise an intruder such as
Trudy can impersonate Alice and
Bob by simply doing record and replay.
Therefore, R1 and
R2 should be large, random values.
Another security precaution is
that the shared secret key,
KAB, needs to be protected.
Because if Trudy can
steal a copy of the key,
let's say from one of the complication
end points either on Alice or
Bob, then she can impersonate
either Alice or Bob.
In other words,
the security of the end points is
as important as the security of
the link between the two end points.